[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show an
FBI agent who has been absolutely
destroyed smeared and pilloried by
president donald trump was sharply
criticized in a new Justice Department
report and he has been escorted out of
the FBI building as a disciplinary
process is now going to play out I'm
talking about Peters Strock who was
removed last August from the Special
Counsel Robert molars investigation into
Russian contacts with the Trump campaign
this was the guy whose text messages
were uncovered they were anti Trump text
messages that he exchanged with an FBI
attorney named Lisa Paige and indeed he
has been reassigned to the FBI's Human
Resources Division and has since been
escorted out this is going to be played
up by the trumpets as vindication that
the entire investigation is bogus and a
witch-hunt when of course it's not this
is actually a guy who was involved
way back when who has since not been
involved and whose participation in this
investigation when you consider the size
and scope of it is almost completely
insignificant you're not going to see
trumped-up bogus charges brought forward
as a result of this guy exchanging
anti-trump text messages with lisa page
you're just not and the idea that this
proves any kind of broader wrongdoing is
laughable but you know that that's what
they're going to claim in reality it
proves the opposite right that this
whole FBI investigation is credible
message they found out that Robert
Miller found out about these text
messages these exchanges and he did the
right thing immediately didn't even
question it for a second because it's
better to just get this guy out that's
not gonna look good if the public finds
out about it which they did eventually
but Molly did the right thing it's what
the Trump administration should be doing
right the Trump administration goes out
of its way to defend people whose
actions don't warrant order or even
deserve a defense
people that should be immediately told
to resign stick around
scott pruett should have been gone a
long list of people Kristen Nielsen
should be resigning for her role in this
entire child internment fiasco
if the Trump administration took the
lead of how quickly and efficiently and
correctly the Moller team dealt with
this we would be much better off as a
country have you taken a look at the
text message exchanges between struck
and page I know I did a while ago I
don't remember the exact details that
yeah I mean most of it was just
flirtatious nonsense I guess but
Republicans wants to hone in on the text
from Peter saying that Trump won't be
President will stop him before it
happens at Lee you know make me if they
think that there would be some like coup
at the FBI the deeps taking over so that
Trump wouldn't be able to get elected
you might have really meant we're gonna
vote against him we're gonna vote again
delay in a vote for hell I think he was
also trying to impress Lisa Paige a
woman with whom he was having an affair
so that that seems like the more
reasonable explanation to me yeah and it
is Trump's razor tells us that usually
the most accurate explanation is the
dumbest one when it comes to actions by
the Trump administration but I think
Occam's razor actually applies when it
comes to Peter Strock which is no he he
wasn't involved in some super secret
Overlord cabal that was going to
forcefully removed from from power or
manipulate election results it was
probably a combination of flirtatious
hubris and just his personal desire to
vote for someone other than Donald Trump
and that's it an apparently Peter struck
is willing to testify before Congress
you can't say the same thing about a lot
of these Trump officials who are getting
in trouble now yeah if they are going to
if they are going to testify before
Congress they want to make sure it's
behind closed doors no cameras no
nothing the transparency that we're
actually seeing around this Peter Strock
issue from struck himself and from the
Moller team exceeds by orders of
magnitude the transparency that we are
actually seeing from the Trump
administration about what the hell
happened during the election
study after study has found that
partisan beliefs and bias what we
believe is factually true this is
something that's been studied for a very
long time
great behavioral economists like Daniel
Kahneman have studied exactly this type
of phenomena for decades when you have a
particular set of beliefs and you're
presented with confirmatory data you are
much more likely to believe that data to
be reliable and accurate then if you are
presented with contradictory data which
can actually further ingrain you in your
beliefs even if the contradictory data
is accurate there's a new study from the
Pew Research Center which takes a sort
of step back and asks how good Americans
are at evaluating the accuracy of a
factual statement versus an opinion
statement and whether they are more
likely to be biased in that opinion
based on their pre-existing beliefs and
here the important thing is how are we
defining a fact versus an opinion what
pew meant by a fact is that something
could be proven or disproven by evidence
all of the factual statements that were
used in the study were true to try to
keep the results more consistent but
respondents didn't know that as far as
respondents knew the factual statements
could have been true they might have not
been contrast that with opinion
statements which are based on the values
and beliefs of the speaker you can't
prove or disprove an opinion statement
in the way that Pugh formulated the
opinion statements and the study asked
people to identify a statement as a fact
whether or not you think it's accurate
or an opinion whether or not you agree
with it and what it found was that if
participants were presented with a fact
that they agreed with they were much
more likely to say this is a fact
whereas if they were presented with
something that was a fact that they did
not believe they were much more likely
to say this is an opinion yeah and as
Stephen Colbert once said reality has a
well-known liberal bias I think this
study shows that one problem might be
with this methodology that it seems like
the facts tend to have a little bit of a
left-wing skew to them do you mean the
reality for example a our reality but
you know I think it's important maybe to
mix up the questions some favourable to
conserve
some favorable to the Liberals okay let
me read a few of them one is President
Barack Obama was born in the United
States obviously that's more of a
liberal minded question right because
they're the ones who are going to admit
to that immigrants who are in the US
illegally have some rights under the
Constitution also a little bit more
liberally slanted bomb or not and health
care costs or Pearson are in the u.s.
are higher than in any other country in
the developed world it's not an opinion
question but they do seem liberally
slanted in a sense does that not matter
I don't know should they mix it up I
mean that the problem is when you start
cherry-picking which facts the the idea
was merely to evaluate whether people
are more or less likely to identify a
fact as a fact if they disagree with it
so this also looked at answers from
Democrats Republicans and independents
and all groups regardless of whether the
the question was a question that is
meant to appeal more to liberals or
Democrats based on the subject matter
all groups were more likely to identify
facts they agree with as facts whether
they were Democrats or Republicans
it's accounted for sort of in the
results so I don't know that it's that
relevant in this case oh yeah I'm sure I
agree with you I just think it's
important to keep our control groups as
steady as possible right and make sure
there's no built-in biases and if there
are maybe add some questions that are a
little bit more favorable to the
right-wing just we have so we have a
sense of if neither one lines up their
opinions with the reality I get what
you're saying I think that they were
correct to divide the answers by
political orientation and that sort of
undoes that element of bias that's my
that's my sense of it Ted Cruz and Jimmy
Kimmel played a game of basketball for
charity and I have some actually really
strong feelings about something that
sounds really insignificant and mealy
meaningless I'm gonna just first play
for you a little bit of the video from
this one-on-one basketball game that
they played see this is a good lesson
for you and those kids in that detention
center
what about all the kids Obama detained
yeah if they're worried you should have
done something about that too
unfortunately all that talk can't get
Jimmy Kimmel a bucket he needs a bucket
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
so anyway clearly I think Ted Cruz the
better basketball player but I have some
real problems with this thing that they
did it's great to raise money for
charity whatever right it's it's all
fine well and good I don't like the idea
that Ted Cruz was put in this position
when he's doing absolutely despicable
things politically although it's true
that he is one of the earlier
Republicans to actually seem to want to
put together some kind of solution
to the child internment camp situation I
just don't like that he's kind of being
humanized in this way and it becomes fun
and games but yet they still discuss
politics during it right I would have
liked to see it just be basketball if
that's what they want to do for charity
but the fact that such serious political
issues were sort of in a clever or funny
way offhandedly discussed during the
thing I just didn't like it I thought it
Emin eyes dorable beliefs from Ted Cruz
Ted Cruz well the political
trash-talking was pretty awkward he
never really saw that from Kobe Bryant
or Paul Pierce back in the day well we
don't know we didn't they did weren't
miked up during the games but yeah I get
imagine they're talking politics but you
could argue to that Jimmy Kimmel started
it because he tweeted out a picture
comparing Ted Cruz's appearance to a
blobfish yeah but that's not political
yeah but then Ted Cruz challenged him to
a basketball game and he won by two
apparently he is the superior basketball
player all those it was pretty pathetic
to watch both of them they're not really
in shape or good at basketball do you
like this type of thing in general yeah
as long as you keep the trash-talking
out of it like I liked watching Justin
Trudeau box a political rival of his in
the Canadian Parliament and that was
pretty entertaining to me yeah I don't
mind the concept I actually do think
that these types of things are
interesting and I'm all about raising
money charity but something about the
way in which politics was mixed with the
game I know something about it just
rubbed me the wrong way and I have a
hard time really putting a finger on
exactly what it was obviously I sided
with Jimmy Kimmel on politics and just
you know being a good person over Ted
Cruz but I thought Jimmy Kimmel was
delivering some low blows particularly
because his family was there after the
game and
he said to Ted Cruz's daughters well you
got to see your dad win something which
is it's pretty funny but you know you're
actually kids that's like that's the the
statement I approve of the most actually
that's pretty clever apparently gonna
watch out for that Ted Cruz hookshot
yeah he's pretty good that one that'll
get you and even when he was closely
defended he still knocked down a couple
of jumpers but Ted Cruz is still one of
the most extreme and deplorable
ideological conservatives in the Senate
and he should be voted out as soon as
humanly possible which apparently will
be November that's as soon as it's
possible to vote him out we don't know
if he will be but please vote against
Ted Cruz I think you could beat Ted Cruz
at a basketball game I think I could I
don't know I think I think I could beat
him I I'm not great at basketball and
he's probably taller than me would be my
guess but I think I probably could beat
Ted Cruz at basketball
they were pretty winded after the first
couple possessions yeah I don't think I
would have much of a problem
I would I would try to use speed against
Cruz more than anything else that we
mind kind of wearing because you did
seem to tire pretty quickly
I'm also six to and half his age so I
think I would win yeah that could be
that let's see if we can set that up at
that okay that would be a good
fundraiser for patreon and membership I
think so I think so
start tweeting to Ted Cruz that he
should face off against producer Pat in
a one-on-one basketball game thanks to
all of our members and patrons
appreciate your support we will have a
brand new bonus show for you tomorrow
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]